so a few videos ago I told you that
anything to the zeroth power is equal to
1 so X to the zeroth power is equal to 1
and I gave you 1 argument why this is
the case that you know I use the example
of you know if we have 3 to the first
power that is equal to 3 3 to the second
power is equal to 9 3 to the third power
is equal to 27 so every time we decrease
by a power we're dividing by 3 27
divided by 3 is 9 9 divided by 3 is 3
then 3 divided by 3 is 1 and so that
should be what 3 to the zeroth power is
so that's one way to think about it the
other way to think about it is that we
need this for the exponent properties to
work or example I told you that a to the
B times a to the C is equal to a to the
B plus C now what happens if C is 0 what
happens if we have a to the B times a to
the 0 well by this property this needs
to be equal to a to the B plus 0 which
is equal to a to the B so a to the B
times a to the 0 must be equal to a to
the B if you divide both sides of this
times a 2 let me rewrite this a to the B
times a to the 0 if we use this property
up here
must be equal to a to the B right B plus
0 is B if you divide both sides by a to
the B you divide both sides by a to the
B what do you get the left-hand side
you're left with just a to the 0 right
these cancel out a to the 0 is equal to
1 and you could use a similar argument
and pretty much all of the exponent
properties that we need anything to the
zeroth power to be equal to 1 it also
makes sense as we divide by 3 in each
step as we decrement our exponent it
keeps working when you take 3 to the
negative 1 power 3 to the negative 1
power we saw in the last video that
that's equal to 1 over 3 to the first
power or one third so once again from 3
to 0 to 1/3 you're dividing by 3 again
it really makes sense on some level that
three to the zeroth power is equal to
one but that leaves a little bit of a
gap what about zero to the zeroth power
this is a very strange notion zero
multiplied by itself zero times and it
depends what context you're using
sometimes people will say that this is
undefined but many more times at least
in my experience this will be defined to
be one so defined to be e one and the
reason why even though this is
completely non-intuitive and you could
type in zero to the zeroth power in
Google and it'll give you one
the reason even though this is
completely non-intuitive the reason why
this is defined to be this way is that
it makes a lot of formulas work and then
what in particular the binomial formula
works the but for your binomial
coefficients which I'm not going to go
over right here when 0 to the zeroth
power is equal to 1 so that's an
interesting thing for you to think about
what that might even mean so let's talk
about some of the other properties and
then we can we can put them all together
with a couple of example problems I told
you in the last video what it means to
raise to a negative power a to the
negative 1 power
or maybe I should say a to the negative
B power is equal to 1 over a to the B
power so just to do that with a couple
of concrete examples 3 to the negative 3
power is equal to 1 over 3 to the 3rd
power which is equal to 1 over 3 times 3
times 3 which is equal to 1 over 27 if I
were to ask you what if I were to ask
you what one-third one-third let's say
to the negative 2 power is well this is
going to be equal to 1 over one-third to
the second power you get rid of the
negative and you inverse it so this is
going to be equal to 1 over what's
one-third times one-third 1/9 which is
equal to this is 1 divided by 1/9 the
same thing as 1 times 9 so this is equal
to 9 and this makes complete sense
because one-third remember one-third is
the same thing as 3 to the negative 1
power right the 3 to the negative
one is one this is equal to 1 over 3 to
the 1 power which is the same thing as
1/3 so if we replace 1/3 with 3 to the
negative 1 this is 3 to the negative 1
to the negative 2 power these two things
are equivalent statements and if we use
some of the proper one of the properties
we learned in the first video we can
take the product of these two exponents
so this is equal to 3 to the negative 1
times negative 2 which is just positive
2 which is equal to 9 so it's really
neat how all of these exponent
properties really fit together in a nice
neat puzzle that they don't they don't
contradict each other it doesn't matter
which property you use you'll get the
right answer in the end as long as you
don't do something crazy now the last
thing I want to define is the notion of
a fractional exponent so if I have
something to a fractional power so let's
say I have a to the 1 over B power I'm
going to define this this is going to be
equal to the beeth root of a so let me
let me be very clear here let me be very
clear let me make it with some numbers
here if I said 4 to the 1/2 power right
there this means this is equivalent to
the square root the square root of 4
which is equal to if we do if we're
taking the principal root this is equal
to 2 so if I were to take let's be clear
if I were to take 8 to the 1/3 power
this is taking the cube root of 8 and
this is on some level one of the most
sometimes confusing things in exponents
here I'm saying what number times itself
three times is equal to 8 so if I said
that X let me do this if I were to say
that X is equal to 8 to the 1/3 power
this is the exact same thing as saying X
to the third power is equal to 8 and how
do I know that these are equivalent
statements
well I could take both sides of this
equation to the third power if I take
the left-hand side of the third power
and the right hand side of the third
power what do I get
left-hand side I get X to the third on
the right-hand side I get 8 to the 1/3
times 3 which is just 3 over 3 which is
just 1 so if X is equal to 8 to the 1/3
if X is equal to 8 to the 1/3 what is X
well 2 times 2 times 2 is equal to 8 and
there's no really easy way especially
when you go to like the fourth root or
the fifth root and you have decimals of
calculating these you probably need a
calculator most of the time to do these
but things like 8 to the one-third or 16
to the 1/4 if they're 27 to the
one-third they're not too hard to
calculate now let's so this right here
let me be clear is 2 now let's make it a
little bit more confusing let's make it
what is 27 what is 27 to the negative
1/3 power well you know don't don't get
too worried we're just an take it step
by step when you take the negative power
when you take the negative power here
this is completely equivalent to 1 over
1 over 27 to the 1/3 power these two are
equivalent you get rid of the negative
and take 1 over the whole thing and then
what is 27 to the 1/3 power well what
number times itself 3 times is equal to
27 well that's equal to 3 so this is
going to be equal to 1 over 3 not too
bad now I'm going to take it even to
another level make it even more
confusing even more daunting what is
what is let me do something interesting
what is 8 what is 8 to the 2/3 to the
2/3 power now that's that seems that
seems a little bit scary and all you
have to remember is this is the same
thing this is the same thing using our
exponent rules really as 8 squared 8
squared to the 1/3 power how do I know
that well if I multiply these two
exponents this is 2/3 so 8 to the 2/3 is
the same thing as 8 squared and then the
third
then the third root of that but you
could view it the other way this should
also be equal to 8 to the 1/3 power
squared because either way when I
multiply these exponents I get 8 to the
2/3 let's see let's verify for ourselves
that we really do get the same value so
8 squared is 64 we're going to take that
to the 1/3 power down here we have 8 to
the 1/3 we already figured out what that
is that's 2 because 2 to the third power
is 8 so this is 2 squared now what is 64
to the 1/3 what times itself 3 times is
equal to 64 well 4 times 4 times 4 is
equal to 64 or 4 to the third is equal
to 64 4 to the third is equal to 64
which means that 4 is equal to 64 to the
1/3 so this is equal to 4 and lucky for
us 2 squared is also equal to 4 so it
doesn't matter which way you do it you
could take the square and then the third
root or you could take the third root
and then square it you're going to get
the exact same answer now everything
I've been doing has been with actual
numbers let me list you a couple of
problems that just you know bring
everything we've done together using
variables so let's say we wanted to do a
few expressions and we want to make sure
there are no negative exponents in the
answer so let's say I had X to the
negative 3 over X to the negative 7 well
we could there's a bunch of ways we
could view this we could view this as
equal to X to the negative 3 times 1
over X to the negative 7 and what is 1
over X to the negative 7 this is the
same thing as this right here is the
same thing as X to the 7th power right
if you have 1 over something you can get
rid of the 1 over and put a negative in
front of the exponent but if you're
putting a negative in front of a
negative 7 you're going to get X to a
7th so this thing can simplify to X to
the negative 3 times X to the 7th power
and then we can add the exponents and
that is X to the fourth power
now another way a completely legitimate
way we could have done this is we could
have just subtracted the exponents we
could have said well gee this is the
same base this is going to be X to the
negative 3 minus negative 7 power well
negative 3 minus negative 7 that's
negative 3 plus 7 which is equal to X to
the fourth power and then one final way
we could I mean actually there's more
than one final way we could have done
this you get a set X to the negative 3
over X to the negative 7 sorry not
negative x over X to the negative 7 well
X to the negative 3 is the same thing as
1 over X to the third that's that term
right there times 1 over X to the
negative 7 so this would have been equal
to 1 over X to the third times X to the
negative 7 you could add the exponents
so that's equal to 1 over 3 minus 7 is X
to the negative 4 and then this if we
just get rid of the inverse we take the
inverse of it we can put a negative in
front of this negative making it a
positive this is going to be equal to X
to the 4 so no matter how we did it as
long as we're consistent with our rules
we got X to the fourth let's do one more
slightly hairy one and then I think
we'll we'll be done for now let's say
let's say we have 3x squared 3x squared
times y to the three-halves power and
we're going to divide it by we're going
to divide it by x times y to the 1/2
power
well once again this is the same thing
as 3 times the X terms right here so 3
times x squared over x times y to the
three-halves over y to the one-half Y to
the three-halves over Y to the 1/2 well
this is going to be equal to 3 times
what's x squared over X or x squared
over X to the first power that's going
to be equal to X to
the to minus 1 to minus 1 and then this
is going to be x y to the three-halves
minus 1/2 so what does the whole thing
become it becomes 3 times X 2 minus 1 is
just 1 I can just write X there times
three-halves minus 1/2 is 2 halves so
that's y to the 2 halves two halves or
two tooth's that's just the same thing
as Y so this is equal to 3 X Y anyway I
encourage you to do many many more
examples of that but you'll see that
just using the rules that we've been
exposed to in the last few videos you
can pretty much simplify any exponent
expression